لقد قلت أنك تعتقد أن بايدن
يجب أن يأمر بشن ضربات على أهداف مباشرة
في إيران، وتقول إننا بالفعل في
حرب أوسع نطاقًا، وقد حذر الكثيرون بشأن
الأهداف داخل إيران حسنًا، دعني
أوضح أن سبب ملاحقة أهداف
داخل إيران هو أنه  لقد أوضحوا تماما أنهم
يعتبرون ذلك خطا أحمر حسنا
أنا أعتبر قتل الأمريكان خطا أحمر وقد
تجاوزوه أه لكي أه
يثبتوا بوضوح أننا مستعدون للقيام
بما يلزم لمنع إيران من
النجاح من خلال
وكلائها الإرهابيين  في المنطقة أه أعتقد أنه
يجب أن نعلمهم أننا لم نعد
نهتم بخطوطهم الحمراء أكثر من
اهتمامهم بخطوطنا الآن أنا لا أتحدث
عن أه على الأقل في البداية ملاحقة
أهداف يهددها النظام أنا'  أتحدث
عن أشياء مثل أنظمة الدفاع الجوي
داخل القواعد العسكرية الإيرانية في غرب
البلاد حيث
تم تدريب وتسليح مجموعات الميليشيات الشيعية على
مر السنين السفن البحرية الإيرانية أه في
البحر الأحمر سنرى ما هو رد فعلهم
على ذلك وبعد ذلك  يمكننا أن نقرر ما إذا كنا
سنلاحق البنية التحتية النفطية
البرنامج النووي برنامج الصواريخ الباليستية
أه أو مرافق القيادة والسيطرة للنظام
لبايدن حتى لا يوضح
أن الولايات المتحدة تعرف من
يحرك الخيوط في كل هذه
الصراعات في الشرق الأوسط
يخاطر ببساطة  مع استمرار هذا الصراع